parce bonsoir clément gignac bonsoir
quelle lecture vous faites de la
situation du rebond de l'emploi qu'on a
eu au moins donné mais la seule
certitude que nous avons général c'est
que la contraction de l'activité
économique est derrière nous donc ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle mais comme
l'avait mentionné d'un propos
d'ouverture est encore loin de la coupe
aux volets bleus on ne récupère et aux
états unis puis au canada
à peine 10% des emplois perdus dans le
code du québec on a récupéré 30 % faut
dire que dès qu'on finit un peu avant
les autres mais clairement bon le pire
est derrière nous d'ailleurs c'est ce
que la banque tient d'abord à me trouver
plus tôt cette semaine mais on a
l'impression que la reprise est plus
rapide qu'attendu est ce qu est ce que
c'est une bonne impression
oui c'est une bonne impression mais en
même temps on vient de le voir avec
bombardier des licences mène donc des
secteurs qui reprennent d'une personne
très très rapide
par contre d'autres secteurs ça va être
plus difficile vous savez le récupère et
aux etats unis 22 millions 1 pourrait
perdus au canada ou au milieu on n'a pas
perdu
si je regarde lorsqu'on a eu la
récession de 2008 2009
évidemment c'est une cause complètement
différente cette fois-ci c'est pour des
raisons de santé publique
mais ça veut prix c'est un vin qu'on
retourne au niveau d'emploi qu'on avait
connu avant la crise en 2001 je peux
vous donner un autre récession à ce
moment là on parlait de 4,1 donc vous
savez en général ses entours 4,5 jusqu'à
7,1 cette fois ci ça va aller à la
vitesse qu'on veut dire qu'on va trouver
un vaccin
si le vaccin se trouvent rapidement et
distribuer rapidement meute ondes en
suède où vingt deux mois bien là sont là
on peut être encouragée mais si c'est
plus long mais ça va prendre plus de
temps à les retourner le niveau d'emploi
qu'on avait l'an dernier
les marchés ont presque tous repris
leurs pertes
parce que les gouvernements les banques
centrales interviennent parce que la
réouverture de l'économie
essentiellement c'est ce qu'on dit
souvent c'est quoi votre analyse de la
reprise boursière
mais comme on l'a déjà mentionné
ensemble gerald vous savez le marché
boursier toujours un oeil anticipe
toujours la fin de la récession un
environnement et d'écoles quatre mois
avant le creux de l'économie
donc cette fois ci le creux
du marché boursier ces thèmes le 23 mars
dernier est ce que le creux de
l'économie c'était le mois dernier on
commence à se demander c'est paule ka
donc deux mois d'avancé donc les marchés
boursiers carbure non seulement aux
bonnes nouvelles qu'on commence à voir
mais déjà anticipé qu'avec la réaction
rapide du g20 une coordination mondiale
comme jamais on n'avait vu depuis 2008
2009 des baisses de taux en avant des
liquidités prestation canadienne
d'urgence canada toutes sortes de
mesures similaires avant le g20 bien
avec ce moment le hockey il reposait
dépression des années 30
et à ce moment là dans 2 3 ou 4 1
l'économie va retourner à son plein
potentiel peut-être le marché boursier
est un peu trop optimistes
il pourrait avoir une deuxième vague
mais clairement comme vous l'avez
indiqué même le nasdaq est maintenant un
niveau en hausse de 2 pour saint de
absolument le gardien qui a effacé
toutes les pertes en fait est une
fondation c'est que ces cas d'allergies
mais l'uci est excusé a dit non à lévis
vous savez évidemment les secteurs qui
en bénéficient gerald le secteur en
bénéficient le plus actuellement au
niveau de la bourse il dément toutes les
compagnies pharmaceutiques qui est votre
souhait mais secteur de la technologie
de l'information parce que ben content
de retrouver un vaccin
il se pourrait que le télétravail soit
encouragée par plusieurs entreprises
on voit par des sondages chambre de
commerce et et par hydro-québec est
évidemment silicon valley donc à ce
moment le secteur de la technologie
on voit on devance peut-être trois
quatre cinq ans qui aurait pris 4 5 1
sur le fait de tout au moins avec les
applications condos dont le nasdaq est
ce un grand gagnant si on doit trouver
un gagnant à cette copie de ce ne fût et
le s&p 500 on voit vraiment qu'on a
récupéré resteront perd 2 35% au creux
et la perte de 6%
quand on regarde le tsx on perdait 38 %
pour le tsx à toronto
hélas la perte finalement est autour de
10 ou 11 % est ce que les marchés
carburent artificiellement à l'aide
gouvernementale et à l'aide des bars des
banques centrales
mais il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup
d'alternatives vous pouvez financer de
gouvernement américain gouvernement
canadien 0 pour 1 5 % pour les dix
prochaines années
ou tenter votre chance vous
nous faisons de 3,1 non pas deux trois
semaines les banques maintiennent leurs
dividendes en général donc un
investissement intéressant que d'un bon
rendement et garder l'esprit aussi que
de marchés boursiers représentent pas
nécessairement d'économie marché
boursier américain s émeut 540% g ces
technologies les pharmaceutiques alors
que ça va pourtant devoir à 15% de
l'économie et dans le cas du canada
évidemment l'entente qu'on est en train
de voir au niveau de l'opep pour
prolonger le couple de production aide à
la remontée du prix du pétrole et du
dollar canadien comme on peut voir cette
semaine
de quelle façon l'aide des gouvernements
et des banques centrales devraient être
retirés
clément gignac bonne question en 2010
2012 ils ont voulu aller rapidement et
on a eu des problèmes donc cette fois ci
je pense qu'on détecte plus patient
évidemment les taux d'intérêt sont go
beaucoup plus faible autour de zéro mais
faudrait s'attendre sans doute un
changement du côté résume fiscale sans
doute les mieux nantis les grandes
compagnies qui auront bénéficié de cette
aide là je m'attends peut-être un rôle
un relèvement du taux de taxation
mais pour les gens qui nous écoutent
mais le travailleur moyen
je m'attends pas des os du côté de
l'impôt ça va prendre encore un bon
moment à une réduction de la dette
un peu comme on avait vu après la
seconde guerre mondiale ça va a pris 15
ans afin qu'on retourne niveau
d'endettement qu'on avait vu avant la
guerre merci pour cette analyse clément
gignac ce soir bonne fin de semaine au
plaisir